Oh
these soldiers are preparing for an
unusual battle on the soccer field
Brazil is hosting the world cup for the
first time in 64 years and the country
isn't taking any chances a force in
Prague Adhanom is not proposed on
Callahan asada con traje de moda manti
te'o fiska the Pope la sombra severe
Lieutenant Colonel Paulo Silva will be
keeping the peace here in Manaus one of
12 cities where 64 World Cup matches
will be played over the next month es
esto Brasilia certain affair le poids ET
kosygin's st. sempra god my zanpakuto
minuto st. star preparado his troops
have been training for more than a year
to confront any number of scenarios
rowdy foreigners bent on destroying
property angry protesters anarchists
hostage takers even terrorists yo C&R
capo de cuenta se la manifestación
general azad ho jayegi he'll make you
preggers Asif Kapadia head tohana almost
lost enjoy the que esta viendo pie is my
graduation Brazil wants to avoid a
repeat of last year's Confederations Cup
when a series of rallying's turns into
deadly riots copper the Moodle is f-ed
finish a call to the cameras may say
juda test for a youthful thomas hell is
under ash she pregnant astonish image
castle in the society's a cup of the
moon here and yourself and inflation
success
Rio is used to hosting big events
fraught with risks like the Pope's visit
in july two thousand thirteen from
manaus the security challenge is all new
so as much of the equipment the police
will use to gather intelligence hey hey
yes ebay for Mysterio is automation HP
car park at Shea Fuji pessoa a bj to OE
ig2g here Coco Marisa Carranza da Paris
own like any big city Manaus has a
command center to monitor streets and
high-risk areas it's getting a major
upgrade for the World Cup 45 million
dollars of special funding for
everything from state-of-the-art video
to mobile surveillance units plus four
thousand more officers Manaus even has
an app to help residents make immediate
contact with the closest cops and if the
threat is too grave the Army is ready to
roll in essence a proper postage a
contingency cassopolis amelita casa
manifest a sunset on grandpa police a
militant on tampons noise la tropa
Peralta present ragada in torrential
dalida avocado cerro de terminar de la
presenza daha pudding the challenge has
just begun and it won't end with the
world cup final on July thirteenth
the Olympics in Rio are just two years
away